hasta ahorita en nuestro modelo de gasto
planeado hemos estado suponiendo que la
inversión planeada es fija lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es ver cómo la tasa
de interés real modifica la inversión
planeada y modifica la inversión
planeada otra forma de pensarlo es que
queremos poner a la inversión en función
de la tasa de interés real más bien a la
inversión planeada en función de la tasa
de interés real y cuando digo tasa de
interés real no digo nada raro
simplemente es la tasa de interés
nominal pero descontando la tomando en
cuenta los efectos de la inflación he
hecho otros videos en los cuales esto
está más a detalle pero es para pensarlo
facilito es que si no hay inflación
entonces la nominal y la real son
iguales bueno ahorita voy a atacar un
problema muy concreto supongamos que en
este año hay un montón de proyectos va
hay un montón de inversiones que podemos
hacer aquí le pongo proyectos que son
inversiones potenciales
vamos a ponerle proyectos y del otro
lado le voy a poner retorno esperado
entonces las personas que planearon
estos proyectos pues hicieron algunas
hojas de cálculo consideraron riesgos y
probabilidades y llegaron un numerito
dijeron sabes que creemos que vamos a
ganar tanto entonces supongamos que el
proyecto a tiene un retorno esperado de
20 por ciento
él ve de 18 por ciento el cd de 16 por
ciento dejado unos más el de de 10 por
ciento el y de 5 por ciento y el f es de
vamos a ponerle de 2 por ciento y
supongamos que al inicio cuando empieza
todo las tasas de interés son muy altas
las tasas de interés reales supongamos
que r 1 es igual a 19 por ciento de
interés real baja entonces si tenemos un
interés real de 19% y esto de acá son
los retornos esperados entonces cuáles
de estos proyectos se van a realizar
cuáles son en los que conviene invertir
entonces saber vamos con la que pasa si
alguien tiene el efectivo para
realizarlo podría prestar lo por 19 por
ciento o realizar el proyecto y dan al
20% si tienen el efectivo lo van a hacer
verdad si no tienen el efectivo
en tomar prestado por 19% e invertir en
nada y de ahí llegan un poco entonces el
proyecto a definitivamente se va a
realizar
qué pasa con ve a ver con él ve hay dos
opciones si se tiene el efectivo para
hacer el proyecto b entonces se puede
hacer el proyecto b y ganar 18 por
ciento o bien prestar el dinero que
obtener 19 por ciento de retorno
entonces pues no vamos a hacer el
proyecto ve de hecho no vamos a hacer
ninguno con menor retorno y por otro
lado si podemos hacer el ve pero hay que
pedir prestado entonces hay que pedir
prestado a 19 por ciento de tasa de
interés real pero vamos a ganar sólo 18
por ciento entonces no conviene porque
perdemos dinero y entonces no vamos a
hacer nivel ni ninguno con menor retorno
baja entonces con una tasa de interés
alta sólo vamos a realizar el proyecto
el proyecto proyecto y pensemos en qué
sucede si la tasa de interés disminuye
supongamos que baja digamos a r1 no le
voy a poner
r2 va
r2 que la nueva tasa de interés real
baja de 19% a digamos 3% va algo así
bueno entonces otra vez el proyecto así
claramente lo vamos a hacer si tenemos
el efectivo conviene más ganar 20 por
ciento que prestarlo por 3 por ciento si
no tenemos el efectivo podemos pedir
prestado a 3 por ciento y ganar 20 por
ciento bueno por la misma lógica también
se va a realizar el proyecto b se puede
pedir prestado a 3 por ciento y ganar 18
por ciento o si tienes el dinero tienes
18 por ciento contra 3 por ciento que
conviene más invertir lo puedes hacer
todos estos hasta antes bueno hasta es
verdad si tienes el dinero entonces te
conviene más invertir en el que
prestarlo a una tasa del 3% y si no
tienes el dinero entonces pides prestado
a 3% haces te ganas un 5% y tienes un
retorno positivo el único que no se va a
hacer es el de acá de verdad el proyecto
efe porque acá abajo pues no estamos
cubriendo el costo de tomar prestado
verdad si hay que tomar prestado para
ganar 2% pues no tiene sentido si
tenemos el dinero es mejor prestarlo a
3% que invertirlo en 2%
el f no se va a realizar ok entonces en
esta situación y de hecho en ninguna se
hace efe
entonces con esta tasa se van a realizar
todos
- efe se invierte en nada
de eso si es también entonces de e y f
no para el f no se realiza
entonces usamos esto para pensar cómo se
vería una gráfica vamos a dibujarla si
hiciéramos una gráfica en donde en este
eje de por acá tenemos pues la inversión
le voy a poner la inversión en función
de la tasa de interés real y por acá le
voy a poner la tasa de interés real r
para la variable independiente va a ser
la tasa de interés real entonces el
interés es muy alto tenemos poca
inversión sólo tenemos el proyecto a
entonces aquí le pongo solo
aquí es cuando tenemos r1 y luego si
disminuimos el interés a r2 entonces
tenemos muchísima más inversión verdad
realizamos todos excepto efe entonces
tenemos un nivel muy alto de inversión
muy bien aquí es a b c d
entonces como puedes ver hay una
relación inversa verdad mientras menor
sea la tasa de interés mayor inversión
se va a realizar y a mayor interés real
se va a realizar menos inversión
podríamos debatir si aquí hay que unirlo
con una curva o con una línea pero por
simplicidad vamos a suponer que se ve
más o menos así como una línea sin mejor
voy a dibujar la línea punteada porque
así me ayuda más a dibujarla como línea
algo así con esto ya podemos empezar a
pensar como la tasa de interés real
desplaza la curva de gasto agregado en
nuestro modelo de cruz keynesiana a
partir de eso después vamos a poder
platicar de la curva y ese la famosa
curva y ese de modelo y s l